hatte war damals lukas lieben freunde
peyton wurde ins auto eingebrochen du
hast mich noch mal dran ändern das ist
nicht so schlecht das ist uns heute
morgen passiert da werde ich am ende
dieses videos der nummer kurz auf einen
den wert euch auf heckens video dazu
verlinken falls ihr helfen möchte
darum soll es heute allerdings nicht
gehen sondern hier um das ist bitter und
wir müssen irgendwie erstmal ein
geschlecht auswählen bin wie männlich
oder weiblich bleib ich
schönere klamotten du hast keine
klamotten mehr
also klicken wir jetzt mal hier auf
weiblich und wir müssen nun auswählen
wer wir sein möchten magdalena decker
elisa bosnjak oder zolani lang hat die
eliza unser neues leben beginnt ich
wurde hier geboren polen
okay wir sind in deutschland geboren
jetzt nicht mehr bei der geburt wurde
mir das weibliche geschlecht zugewiesen
ich wurde auf der hochzeitsreise meiner
eltern gezeigt das ist super freut mich
aber am 16 juli geburtstag mein
sternzeichen ist krebsart krebs
sternzeichen damit weil ich jetzt nicht
so wie ich schon noch von studien ich
heiße dieser wozniak meine mutter ist 18
jahre alt arbeitslos und heisst michael
killich ich mein vater ist 41 jahre alt
hochzeitsplaner und heisst rafael
wozniak unser bankguthaben es fast so
hoch wie sonst
recht glücklich gesund und klug doch
leider bist du ziemlich unattraktiv
[Musik]
steht zufriedenheit alles folgen im
grünen bereich um ausleben nur elf
prozent naja aber wir sind intelligent
recht nach tippe auf alter um eine älter
zu werden trifft auf seinem lebensweg
entscheidungen und lebe dein bestes oder
schlimmstes leben ob grad perfektes sale
königlichen wäre ich auch dafür dass
vorne machen moment reden und schreiben
kompromiss eingehen ein nickerchen
machen oder weinen ich würde sagen
nickerchen ich würde sagen wir wollen so
wie ich heute morgen okay dann meinen
wir
ich glaube ich kaufe mir mal die app
free-version wenn ich bin ich hier so
ich glaube nicht aber hast hier vor euch
hin dass tierhalter euro
ich hätte macht euren parkhaus
investieren sollen also nutze info
peyton wurden aus dem auto irgendwie
handtaschen im wert von keine ahnung wie
viel geld geklaut und wir haben jetzt
schon wie die auf ihrem kanal
hochgeladen
also wenn ihr das gerne sehen möchte
klickt hier oder warten bis zum ende des
videos kommt dass sie erst mal zu ende
dann guckt etwas anderes erst mal bei
mir das war bei dir bleiben also wir
können jetzt auf jeden fall unser alter
hier verändern klicke jetzt einfach mal
ein bisschen älter werden impfung barth
ja jetzt schon ja natürlich herr du
wirst du immer geld wenn du noch zu
klein ist ging richtig du nicht ich habe
alles besiegt eine mutter geht mit ihr
zum arzt um dich impfen zu lassen wie
verhältst du dich versuchen ruhig zu
bleiben hysterisch werden und ausflippen
beißen reißen
zwei jahre hat er ein bisschen anders
machen dass ich auch was sehen ja ich
klicke mal wieder auf alte höhen sind
wir schon drei jahre deine eltern wollen
die ein tier namens aids kaufen ich
dachte eltern sind getrennt
aber sie können doch trotzdem zusammen
geld ausgeben für dich weil er unsere 23
jahre auseinander dachte diese acht
jahre bei uns wären schon krass acht
hätte bisher geist nur fünf
wäre dann wäre ich bereit sind wie sie
ist deine eltern haben die einen hund
namens nach hause braucht sehr gut
können der name klingt toll aussehen
können wir pusten steht hier unten ab
zum schönheits doc mit drei an die alte
dame von nebenan bietet dir ein cooles
neues lätzchen mit sophia die erste
motiven an in letzter zeit beim essen
einen ganzen klamotten folge sei
dreimal so sexy jetzt wie vorher noch
ein jahr älter gelb du leidest angeblich
nach haben lassen
andere sache vielleicht
kann sich gegen alles impfen lassen wir
gehen noch mal ein jahr mehr sechs jahre
lieblingsfahrer eltern fühlen sich zum
essen aus und fragen sich welches fast
food restaurant lieblingsrestaurant ist
ich mag ein fast mit pizza pepsi der
mcdonald's
mcdonalds nehmer was anderes sagen wir
mögen kein fastfood gemacht dass unser
aussehen doch ein bisschen germany macht
es nicht schade wenn müsste mit sechs ja
nicht mittlerweile in der schule sollen
wo ist das denn so gesungen ich dort
werde so ein geiles letzten bekommen
vielleicht muss man einfach ein bisschen
älter wären das kommt dabei fiel das mit
der zeit grundschule du besuchst jetzt
grundschule ok perfekt aber nochmal ja
älter
protestiert
naja es war mit sieben jahren erste
schon ganz kurz schweigeminute
er war so schön
die menschen angst zustände haben wir
haben angst zustände mit zehn jahren
hier kannst du nur haben wenn du so zum
beispiel so keine ahnung klaustrophobie
oder soll es doch längst zu stellen wir
uns einmal ein prozent liegt und unsere
zufriedenheit bei null prozent liegen
genau das bringt ja nichts wenn wir
unzufrieden sind die sache jetzt hat
allerdings das ich bisher nur auf plus
bei malta geklickt habe kam auf
beziehungen klicken wir haben eine recht
gute beziehung zum vater und zur mutter
halt verreckt wenn ich hier auf
aktivitäten clique sehen wir dass wir
gar keine aktivitäten
hobby wir suchen uns erst mal ein buch
buch gute nacht lieber montag buch lesen
unsere zufriedenheit es 50 prozent steht
jetzt mal auf besitz drauf wir haben gar
nichts weil wir auch noch erst zehn oder
elf jahre alt sind neun sind wir von
einer clique ich jetzt mal die
hochschule können irgendwas für die
meinen wir unsere noten sind auch nicht
so gut gemalt die klassen beliebt hat es
nicht so ganz
wir müssen unsere beliebtheit steigern
bei den klassenkameraden legte jetzt mal
hier auf gehrig wissen jetzt geht drauf
also beziehung ist relativ gering ich
würde sagen wir freuen uns erstmal mit
ihm an warum denn direkt mit dem typen
ein freundlicher abfuhr bekommen
eric aus deiner klasse will sich nicht
mit ihr anfreunden das ist nun mit denen
irgendwie töten sollen wie regen einfach
mal beleidigen nein nein
listen zufriedener werden was erik aus
seiner klasse freak kommt
jetzt haben wir's dem gegeben so hilft
auch jemand er hat dich angegriffen das
gehirn wurde abgerissen es wird unser
gehirn das gehirn wurde abgerissen was
unsere gesundheit ist bei 14 wenn unser
gehirn rausgerissen wurde mit neun
jahren sind wir tot eigentlich müssen
wir auch mal in unserem aussehen arbeit
weil es ist noch schlechter alter unser
gehirn ist raus und lenkt sein aussehen
der schule haben wir auf jeden fall
nichts im besitz haben wir auch nichts
in den beziehungen haben wir auch nicht
zur gesundheit und aktivitäten können
wir doch dort vom arzt gehen in die
notaufnahme mal ganz schnell suchen auch
heute zudem aus viel besser okay wir
sind in der gesundheit bei 18% liegen
jetzt trotzdem noch mal zum arzt würde
ich sagen also doktor schulmedizinisch
behandeln lassen wir gehen so läuft wie
geschmiert great gegen gelb stellt die
gastgeber
wir haben sechs jahren an gelbfieber
gehabt vielleicht ist das auch ein
bisschen für die angstzustände
verantwortlich gewesen fünf sekunden
später ja du leidest weiterhin ihren
geld wie bei dann ist das jetzt also
konnte ich mich auf alter und wir sind
zehn störenfried vor dem unterricht
siehst du wie isabella aus deiner klasse
1 anthrazit um aus dem pulk von frau
kucharski nimmt und aus dem fenster wenn
das früheren diktat gewesen welche
effekte ich kenne seine worte nicht mal
was wird iris punkt gar kein wort was da
steht was machst du über sie lachen sie
angreifen angreifen die leiste des
opfers wurde mit einem aufwärtshaken
getroffen du hast dir die kniescheibe
angebrochen ist an ihren verletzungen
gestorben
hast du sie gerade umgebracht also wir
bislang hier im knast 10 damit sinken
wir sind zehn jahre und haben menschen
getötet hier sind übels unzufrieden
besitzen fast gar keine gesundheit mehr
weil wir seit neun jahren an gelbfieber
leiden unser aussehen es bei zwei
prozent aber wir haben nur 93
prozentiger intelligenz
von daher würde ich sagen meine liebe
elisa wozniak wir hoffen dein leben war
schön viel spaß im knast wir hoffen dass
ein paar leute auf den platz gehen die
handtaschen abgezogen ich glaube nicht
dass wir die kriegen werden aber naja
und falls ihr euch dafür interessiert
freunde dann klickt gerne auf peytons
kopf denn davon hänge ich euch jetzt
gerade mal das video eingeblendet wie
wir historiker ein bisschen erzählen wie
peyton sachen im gesamtwert von über
60.000 euro geklaut wurden wenn
irgendwas gesehen haben sollte das haben
bekommt keine ahnung was dann klickt
dort gern drauf wir sind für jede hilfe
sehr dankbar sonst könnte ich auf meinen
kopf klicken um einen kanal abonnieren
danke